اهلا بكم وتقبل الله صومكم اصدرت المحكمه
الجنائيه المركزيه العراقيه حكما بالاعدام
على 24 عراقيا بتهمه قتل مئات المجندين
العام الماضي في قاعده سيكر بتكريت الحكم
صدر بعد جلسه واحده استمرت اربع ساعات
وانكر خلالها المدانون التهم الموجه اليهم
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما مدى وجاهه الاعتراضات التي
ابداها المدانون ضد عداله الحكم
باعدامهم وكيف ستنعكس احكام الاربعاء على
الشهادات المثاره حول احكام الاعدام في
العراق
في الجلسه الاولى المخصصه لمحاكمه
المتهمين في القضيه التي عرفت اعلاميا
باسم قضيه سبايكر في العراق اصدرت المحكمه
الجنائيه المركزيه يوم الاربعاء احكاما
بالاعدام شنقا على 24 متهما انكر المتهمون
ضلوعهم في المجزره التي وقعت في يونيو عام
2014 وطالب بعضهم
بفحص اثار التعذيب الذي تعرضوا له اثناء
التحقيق لكن المحكمه لم تستجب لهذا الطلب
بل واكدت في المقابل اطمئنانها الى كفايه
الادله المقدمه لادانتهم تقرير فتحي
اسماعيل جلسه واحده فحسب كانت كافيه
للمحكمه الجنائيه العراقيه لتقضي بالاعدام
شنقا حتى الموت على 24 متهما في القضيه
المعروفه اعلاميا بمجزره سبايكر حيث قضى
وفق روايه سلطات بغداد ما لا يقل عن 1700
مجند غالبيتهم من الطائفه الشيعيه على
ايدي مسلحين في معسكرهم بمدينه تكريت في
محافظه صلاح الدين صيف 2014 غدات اجتياح
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه مناطق في
العراق اعتبرت المحكمه الادله كافيه للحكم
باعدام المتهمين استنادا الى البند الرابع
من قانون الارهاب المثير للجدل لكن
المتهمين نفو التهم الموجهه اليهم بل اكد
عدد منهم انهم لم يكونوا في تكريت اصلا
يوم الحادثه وقالوا ان اعترافاتهم خلال
التحقيق اخذت منهم تحت التعذيب وطلب بعضهم
من قاضي المحكمه اجراء كشف طبي للتاكد من
اثار التعذيب على اجسادهم اخرون ذكروا
انهم لم يلتقوا محاميا قبل محاكمتهم ولعل
ما يزيد الشكوك حول سلامه الم كمه اضافه
الى ما تقدم هو ان الادله التي قدمتها
المحكمه اقتصرت على صور فيديو لاعدام
المجندين نشرت العام الماضي على شبكه
الانترنت على ان هذه المحاكمه العاجله
التي لم تتجاوز مداولاتها ساعات اربع تسلط
الضوء على حاله القضاء العراقي عموما وما
يلاحقه من اتهامات محليه ودوليه بافتقاد
العداله والاستقلاليه لا سما في ظل اجواء
الاحتقان الطائفي التي تعصف بالبلاد
والمزايدات بشان الحرب ضد تنظيم الدوله
ويقبع في السجون العراقيه الان الاف
المحكومين بالاعدام بتهم الارهاب غالبيتهم
الساحقه من السنه ويجري العمل للاسراع
بتنفيذ الاحكام ضدهم استباقا لقانون العفو
العام الذي كان يتوقع ان يقره البرلمان
سعيا لفتح صفحه جديده في العراق اذا كانت
رئاسه الجمهوريه هي التي عرقلت حتى الان
تنفيذ تلك الاعدامات بحجه الشك في عدالتها
فان تعديلا اقره مجلس الوزراء الشهر
الماضي قضى بتولي وزير العدل اجازه
الاعدامات في حال لم تفعل الرئاسه ذلك
خلال شهر من صدور الاحكام
وتؤكد منظمه العفو الدوليه والامم المتحده
ايضا ان احكام الاعدام في العراق طبقت
بموجب قانون مكافحه
ال يفتقد لدقه والوضوح حسب تعبيرهم كما
سبق لبانك مون ان اعتبر العام الماضي ان
احكام الاعدام تتم بشكل طائفي ولا تخفي
الجهات الحقوقيه انزعاجها من مخالفه دستور
العراق للمعايير الدوليه لحقوق الانسان
برفضه منح الرافه او العفو في قضايا
الارهاب كما تفعل كل دساتير
العالم نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من بغداد
السيده عاليه نصيف عضو عضوه اللجنه
القانونيه في البرلمان العراقي ومن لندن
محمد الشيخلي مدير المركز الوطني للعداله
نبدا بالسيده نصيف في في بغداد سيدي نصيف
بلا شك مجزره سبايكر هي مجزره مروعه
ووحشيه للغايه ولكن هل احكام الاعدام التي
صدرت احترمت المعايير المتعارف عليها
للمحاكمه
العادله نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه
لك وتحيه لضيفك الكريم وتحيه لمشاهدي اهلا
وسهلا حقيقه هناك عده معايير توضح بشكل
كامل عداله المحكمه اولا ان المحكمه علنيه
وهذه هي احد المعايير التي تعطي نوع من
الشفافيه لمثل هكذا
محاكمات المحاكمه جرت بحضور الشهود الامر
الثالث هناك عدد من النواب كانوا حاضرين
هذه المحاكمه المحاكمه تمت من من قبل
المحكمه المركزيه الجنائيه التي تاسست منذ
عام
1921 تكونت من ثلاث قضاه كهيئه ثانيه
بوجود مدعي عام المعيار الثالث دائما
التحقيقات هي التي تتاخر وليس المحاكمات
انا كقانون اعلم جيدا بان كل الاجراءات
القانونيه تستنفذ في مرحله التحقيق في في
في ما يتعلق بالاطلاع على الافادات فيما
يتعلق في كشف الدلاله فيما يتعلق
بالاستماع الى اصحاب المدعي الشخصي كل هذه
الامور استنفذت في التحقيق انت تعلم اليوم
هؤلاء الذي تم مسكهم في قضيه
سبايكر يعني اكثر من سنه الاجراءات بحقهم
تسير كقضيه تحقيق فبالتالي لا تحتاج
المحكمه بعد مطابقه الافادات مع محاضر
الادله الجنائيه مع الشواهد والوقائع الى
ان تحتاج الى اعاده النظر في المحاكمه ثم
الشفافيه الاخرى لهذه المحكمه هناك طرق
طعن بعد هذا القرار هذا القرار ليس قطعيا
هناك عاده هناك تمييز هناك تصحيح يح هناك
اعاده محاكمه حتى عندما تم
سن العفو العام ونا اردنا ان نقلص حاله
الاعاده لتكرارها فتحنا نافذه في العفو
العام بان تكون هناك اعاده محاكمه اعتقد
كل هذه الامور هي معيار ل ان تستنفذ فيها
طرق القانونيه جميعا وهذه معيار مثبته في
جميع قوانين دول المنطقه سيد شيخي ما رايك
في هذه الملاحظات التي ذكرتها السيده
نصيف شكرا محمد بالتاكيد بقدر حزننا
والمنا على كل
الضحايا من قبل الارهاب بكل صنوفه وانواعه
وبقدر المنا حقيقه على دماء الابرياء
الذين يذهبون يوميا
نتيجه تصرفات التنظيمات الارهابيه او حتى
من ارهاب الدوله ولكن هذا لا يعطي مبررا
على الاطلاق ان يساق بعض الابرياء لغرض ان
يكون هنالك ارضاء للشارع او لطائفه معينه
على حساب الابرياء من خلال متابعتي
الدقيقه لهذه المحكمه بكل تفاصيلها منذ
لحظات القاء القبض على هؤلاء الصبيه
والشباب
وسوقهم الى المحكمه وهي محكمه للاسف
استطيع ان اقول انها سوريه وشكليه افتقدت
الى ادنى معايير المحاكمات العادله
والدليل ان المحكمه استندت فقط الى
اعترافات المتهمين الذين انتزعت منهم
نتيجه ممارسه التعذيب بحقهم وهذا ما ورد
بلسان كل هؤلاء المتهمين اثناء المحاكمه
التي لم تدم سوى اربعه ساعات المحكمه لم
تستند الى اقوال شهود عيان المحكمه استندت
الى شهادات سماعيه والمعروف في المحاكم
الجنائيه ان المحكمه لا تعتد نهائيا باي
شهاده سماعيه كل الشهود الذين قدموا في
هذه المحكمه كانوا على السماع وبالتالي لا
يعتد بشهاداتهم من الناحيه القانونيه كشف
الدلاله كل كشف الدلاله المربط بهذه
الدعوه لكل المتهمين يتناقض مع اعترافات
المتهمين هؤلاء وبالتالي هذا لا يعطي
مبررا للمحكمه ان تولد قناعه بناء على
اعترافات هي تدرك جيدا بانها انتزعت نتيجه
اكراه ونتيجه تعذيب مورس بحق هؤلاء
الابرياء حقيقه نحن لا ندعو الى تبرئه من
ارتكب جرما ولكن ندعو الى ضروره ان تكون
هنالك محاكمات عادله محاكمات نزيهه تعطي
لكل ذي حق حقا وحقه وبالتالي لا تذهب
المحكمه الى اجندات
سياسيه لغرض ارضاء بعض الطوائف او ارضاء
الراي العام العراقي نعم اشرت الى نقطتين
مهمتين اسال عنهما السيده نصيف موضوع ال
ال قول المتهمين او المدانين بانهم
اعترفوا نتيجه التعذيب
ونقطه ان اغلب الشهادات هي شهادات سمعيه
مثل ما قال سيد شيخي اضيف نقطه ثالثه حتى
تجيب على ثلاث نقاط مع بعضهم يقال انه
اغلب اغلب الادله الادانه بين قوسين
ارتكزت على اشرطه فيديو على تسجيل
مصوره هل هذه المسائل الثلاث يمكن ان تطعن
في في عداله المحكمه سيده
نصيف اولا المحاكم انا ذكرت لك المحكمه
الجنائيه المركزيه تاسست من عام 1921 وهم
من خيره القضاه الموجودين فيها ليس قضاه
حاليين وانما قضاه اخذوا التدرج والتسلسل
القضائي لحين ما وصل للقضيه الجنائيه
الامر الاخر الجريمه التي ارتكبت في في
صلاح الدين الاعتراف التي الاعترافات التي
جاءت والشهود التي جاءت من ذات المحافظه
من ممثلي تلك المحافظه حددوا الاسماء
حددوا الشخصيات قبل ان يتم القاء القبض
عليهم يعني كمرحله
اولى الجانب الاخر اللي انت جنابك تقول
بان هي القضيه قضيه سياسيه الجانب الاخر
كان لا يعلم من هي الشخصيات نحن كان لدينا
تصور بان داعش من ارتكب هذه الجريمه ولكن
بالبحث والتحقيق من من ممثلي تلك
المحافظات من شهود عيان من تلك المحافظات
اكدوا بان من كب هذه الجريمه هي بايادي
عراقيه واعطوا للجهات المختصه اسماء
الجنات بشكل كامل اليوم العشائر تعرف
بعضها البعض هي من اعطت اسماء هؤلاء
وعندما تم القبض عليهم تمت الامور وفق
اولا يعني انت هسه اليوم هسه اني قانونيه
عندما تحصل مثل هذا لحت تطابق الاعترافات
مع الوقائع اللي هي الكشف الدلاله و
وتتثبت من هذه الوقائع في مكان الجريمه
الامر اخر هناك هناك محاضر ادله موجوده
ثابته
ودامغة اماء كامل بان من ارتكب هذه
الجريمه هم عراقيين هل جاؤوا من السماء هل
ملائكه السماء هو من ارتكب الجريمه بحق
1700 شاب ابناء المحافظه هم من استدلوا
وهم من اعطوا الجهات المختصه الاسماء
وكانت اعتراف الاعترافات التي جاءت والتي
دمغت اعترافات الجناد ابناء المحافظه
اللسته جاءت من ابناء المحافظه نعم سيده
نصيف انت قانونيه والسيد شيخلي قانوني
بالتالي انا الوحيد بينكم اللي مش قانوني
لكن مع ذلك اسال سيد شيخلي يعني صحيح ان
المتهمين يعني قالوا انهم تعرضوا للتعذيب
ولكن اذا كانت الشهادات التي تدينهم مثل
ما تقول سيده نصيف هي لاناس يعرفون هذه
الشخصيات جيدا
وا اعترفوا بانهم هؤلاء فعلا من قاموا ترى
ذلك غير
كافي هذا غير كافي من الناحيه القانونيه
المحاكم جنائيه تستند الى ادله يجب ان لا
يشوبها اي خطا او لا يشوبها
اي يعني شكن في صحتها وبالتالي حتى المبدا
المعروف يعني ما يسمى بالاعتراف سيد
الادله هذا لا يعتد به امام المحاكمه
الجنائيه فالاعتراف ليس سيد الادله من
الناحيه القانونيه ان لم يعزز بادله
قانونيه معتمده و معتبر قانونا من الناحيه
الجنائيه وذلك كشهادات عيان كما ذكرت ان
يتطابق
الاعتراف الاعتراف مع كشف الدلاله ان
تتوافر ادله كبصمات الاصابع ك الاسلحه
الاسلحه الجرميه المواد الجرميه التي
المبرز في القضيه هذا كله غير موجود انا
حقيقه استغرب من اي شخص ذو عقليه قانونيه
ولو كانت ابتدائيه ان ان يتوافق مع قرار
محكمه صدر بناء على افلام قد تكون هذه
الافلام غير صحيحه وقد تكون هذه الافلام
ممنتجه وقد تكون هذه الافلام اساسا هي
ليست بهذه الواقعه وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان
القضاء الجنائي العراقي والمحكمه الجنائيه
معروف عنها يعني لدينا ثلاثه قضاه والسيده
عاليه تعرف هؤلاء القضاه المحسوبين على
حزب الدعوه هؤلاء تاتي اوامر ويصدرون
قرارات بعيدا عن اي قواعد قانونيه معتبره
او معتمد عليها في المحاكم الجنائيه لا
اريد ان اذكر اسمائهم حتى لا تتعرض حياتهم
الى الخطر ولكن انا اعتقد بان القضاء
الجنائي العراقي يجب ان يتخلص من هؤلاء
القضاه الدمج الذين سببوا وصمات عار بحق
بحق تاريخ القضاء العراقي لان هؤلاء يا
سيدتي عال مسيسين وانت تدركين بان بعض
القرارات صدرت صباحا ونقضت مساء وهذا
حقيقه يعتبر مهزله في في المحاكم العراقيه
هذا حقيقه سبب احراج الى كثير من زملائنا
القضاه الذين يعتمدون على الادله وعلى
العلم الجنائي والقواعد القانونيه ولكن ان
يع الماجورون الذين يعتمدون التسييس فهذا
حقيقه ظل
في حق القضاء العراقي
وبتال بعد اذنك هو هذه الاحكام هذه
الاحكام سيد شيخلي هذه الاحكام بلا شك س
تزيد من الجدل ومن الشبهات التي تثار فيما
يتعلق بالقضاء العراقي فيما يتعلق باحكام
الاعدام تحديدا نريد ان نعود الى هذه
النقطه بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الجدل بشان احكام
الاعدام في العراق في ضوء الحكم الصادر
باعدام 24 شخص في القضيه المعروفه اعيا
بقضيه سبايكر سيده نصيف اذا تركنا هذه
القضيه وننتقل منها الى ما يثار دائما
خاصه بين المنظمات الدوليه الحقوقيه فيما
يتعلق باحكام الاعدام في العراق بشكل عام
وعدم احترامها ل المعايير و شبهه السياسه
فيها هل يمكن ان يزيد هذا الحكم من الجدل
المثار يعني حقيقه انا استغرب من ان يقال
بان افلام منتجه لشخص قانوني هو خارج خارج
الحدود اليوم نحن حتى الافلام التي عرضت
كانت مطابقتها مع الشخص الذي ارتكب هذه
الجريمه ثم المحكمه لم تستند على فقط
الافلام ذهبت بهؤلاء الاشخاص الى موقع
الجريمه وقام بعمل كشف دلا
الاص الين الا انكروا قال لسنا نحن من
يوجد في هذا الري العزيز ه انت ه جنابك
جنابك انت عرضت هسه في بدايه لقا ماتك
فيلم انا اذكره كل الزين هذا مال عرس
الدجيل ماله علاقه بقضيه سبايكر فهذه
القضيه احنا نحن اهل البلد موجودين نحن
لدينا ثقه بقنا لدينا اولا ثلاث قضاه وليس
قاضي واحد وانا متاكده منهم بانهم ق
يتمتعون بالنزاهه والكفاءه الامر الاخر
هناك مدعي عام الامر الاخر هناك طرق طعن
اذ ما كانت هناك شكوك في هذه طرق الطعن
نحن متيقنين جدا من ان القضاء العراقي
قضاء سليم ولا نسمح باي تجريح يعني بقضائه
اما اما فيما يتعلق بما يثار من منظمات
دوليه تقول اليوم تعلم جيدا بان العراق
اصبح محط بيع وشراء لهذه المنظمات الدوليه
يعني تقوللي اليوم الارهاب اللي ده يصير
بالعراق القتال اللي يصير بالعراق اعدد لك
هسه الف جريمه وجريمه تصل الى مستوى
الاباده الجماعيه الى جرائم الى جرائم حرب
هذه من يرتكبها من يرتكبها اذا تريد احنا
كعراقي ترتكب بحق العراقيين بحق مئات
والاف العراقيين ونقول لا هذول لازم اكو
معايير دوليه من نرتكب ما نحكم باحكام
ثقيله كحكام الاعدام اذا اذا انا هذا حنطي
مجال اللي اذا ما ارتكب ما انفذ